[Music]
let's go to jesse in seattle i want to
stay employed hey jesse what's up
hey uh good morning good morning to you
what's up dude
hey man um
shoot it's crazy uh usually i hear you
and little
older people talking
um so now maybe you get to hear a 20
year old talking maybe you can help me
out you're 20
yeah yes sir dude you don't number one
dang don't call me sir
i'm only 24.
and that's not true
and
you sound older than 20 did people tell
you that
um
yeah and then the look too i kind of
have a kind of a beard so they tell me
that too oh people with beards
i have you can't see me right now but i
haven't shaved like nine months i got
nothing oh i got nah no i've seen it
before um i don't think i've ever seen
it with a beard because i can't grow one
it looks all patched out and scratched
out like i've lived in the woods for a
few months
and that's it
and
i don't want to get too ground yes i
can't grow up here dude what i wish it'd
be awesome so good for you i'm glad you
look like an old lumberjack
congratulations thank you thank you do
you wear philson you're from seattle you
wear filson and like cool thick
like
plaid shirts
no
no no i'm on the other side carhartt
jeans boots oh dude real working stuff
because uh yeah i'm a truck driver
actually
you're all the things i'm not jesse so
thanks for kicking me while i'm down
sure appreciate it
sure man gotcha all right so let's see
what we can do here what's up
um so i've been in this uh relationship
um with this shake i i really like her
she's great
for about seven months now seven eight
months okay and i'm having
i'm not sure if it's still like a
learning thing or i'm still trying to
learn her um or if it's amazing or her
thing but um
it's i'm having a little trouble
communicating with her when um when
we're in a disagreement when we're in
argument i'm the type of person to
um
like if something's bothering you let's
sit down let's figure it out right now
she wants to take her break um she wants
some space
and it was it was real hard at first to
kind of get used to because i don't like
carrying like this stuff i just want to
get done and over with
and um but
i think something else is that
she'll have her space and whatnot
but um
she just won't want to come back to the
table and talk about it
and i mean i i think eventually you know
we're gonna have to talk about stuff and
it's not something like super important
it'll be just like little disagreements
and
they'll just kind of blow up and
um i'm wondering how i can get through
her i mean it's kind of a
i'm not sure if it's like a deal breaker
or not
um
i don't mean to offend anybody out there
any any woman's out there all right i
really don't but
i'm trying to watch my words carefully
here no i don't think you're finished
at first i thought it was uh sort of a
once a month type of thing
i was trying to think of all my options
and i really hope i don't find anyone
out there but um yeah i noticed that
maybe that's not the case i don't know
if you
i wouldn't say that i mean i wouldn't go
searching for
yeah i would take that off the table um
well i'm seeing now that that's not the
case anymore yeah could be a little bit
more often i guess
yeah often but more randomly
so
hmm
how can i help let me ask you that cause
i'm gonna start answering a bunch of
questions i don't even know that you're
asking how can i help
how do i
i guess how do i
how do i communicate with her when we
have a disagreement
okay
so do you like this this young woman
oh yeah yeah i love her okay
does she like it when you call her my
chick
um
i've never called her that uh oh just to
me
yeah yeah so
here's
here's what i've picked up in a few
minutes
of just talking with you
you're
um
you're super capable
my guess is you can fix stuff my guess
is you're strong you clearly have a
beard for god's sake you wear carhartt
which is just awesome um
you're able to just fix stuff you're
secure
and
it's hard when you're working on a car
there's not a car that you can't fix
you can just solve it
and so now you've come up against
somebody
and your way of solving things to fix
things there's a
lug nut that's missing let's replace the
lug nut and get on down the road
hey the car needs gas let's put gas in
it what do we do i have to discuss this
let's put gas in and move on down the
road here
and
your girlfriend's behaviors to me
suggest she doesn't feel safe with you
she doesn't trust you
and not in a you're going to cheat on me
kind of way
but in a
um you've already got her figured out
and you're the smart one and you've got
all the answers
and
she just needs to get on with it
and what she's trying to communicate and
she doesn't she's not trying to
communicate this what her body is
communicating is
i need some space
i'm not okay
and i feel like if i tell you what's
going on you're just gonna say well
don't think that way just do this
and is that fair
yeah no yeah it is no it is
and not often but she does come around
she does
say stuff like that
yeah so
and then when you throw in like
oh it clearly can't be me
it must be that she's having a period
or
it clearly isn't
like
um a
i mean there's the answers right there
clearly
so it must be that
fill in the blank
all of this is
um
is somebody's alarm bells going that
guy's not safe and i still love him and
i still want to be around him
and so safety is not you can't fight
people i'm sure you can
um
safety is
not that you don't earn a living you
clearly do safety is like if something
break air conditioner breaks that guy
can help me out great what i'm talking
about safety is
the amygdala part of somebody's brain
human connection
a sitting down and being quiet and
saying tell me what's going on and i'm
not going to try to solve you i'm not
going to try to give you all the answers
back i'm just going to listen
now can she be bananas and bonkers and
fighting about that of course man but
she's done all the fun with me only
person i can i'm talking to is you right
so to go back to your original original
question man i've been with the same
person for 25 years
we've been married 19 and a half of them
um i'm still figuring out ways to
communicate
we're still working through that that is
part of a relationship you will change
over time she will change over time and
you're constantly negotiating what
communication looks like
the greatest gift you can give somebody
is safety
meaning if i tell you what i really feel
right now
you're gonna go thanks for sharing that
with me not that's stupid
or why don't you just do this you tell
that guy he just needs to
that's not what they're looking for
they're looking for your answers looking
for your connection
and that's hard for a bearded carhartt
dude right
it's dude it's hard for me who has no
beard and has these
wannabe carhartt pearl snaps on right
now
i i love the same thing i it's hard
and i will tell you this brother i have
i've hurt my wife
with my charts and my graphs
i've hurt my wife over the years
by
ignoring how she feels and ignoring the
thoughts she has
and her emotions and just trying to get
to quote-unquote answers because i found
out a few years ago
she's way way smarter than me she
doesn't need my answers she just wants
me to be with her does that make sense
yeah so my question for you brother is
do you even want to be with this person
i mean
i absolutely do um do you like her i'm
young but i do do you love her
yeah i do
okay
so do you want to be right
or do you want to be in a relationship
with her
well i guess big picture's you know it's
a thing and i'd rather be with her
okay
because what i'll tell you over time is
hey that wasn't a very secure answer but
i'll i'll just go with it
over time right is going to be through
connection will there be moments you
have to say hey look this guy is for a
real blue yes
that's just not every time
i don't think there's a deal breaker at
all i think you need to reorient
yourself that you're not the smartest
strongest baddest dude in the world
and that she has something to offer you
not vice versa
is that am i way off tell me i'm way off
you know it it makes sense um it really
does it clicks with me but um
uh i'm kind of worried if it's kind of
if this is gonna be like the
like an always type of deal because her
her family is like that uh there was
this one time and i picked up on it
really quick i
i was on a phone with her and um i kind
of heard like some
yelling in the background i guess her
younger sister was like arguing with her
mom she comes from like a mom dad family
um and i guess her mom and her sister
were arguing and it was like kind of
like they were kind of yelling at each
other
and then i i kind of asked her what
happens next and she's like well they
never talk about it they just
go on tour because days after um she
told me something like her mom was
picking up her sister i'm like oh they
get along now and she was like yeah no
they yell at her they're each other they
have their their their fights and then
they just never talk about it and they
go about their normal lives
and so i kind of went kind of aha like
is this possibly maybe this is what
she's used to this kind of like where
it's coming from or is it still
i don't know i just thought maybe it was
worth saying if this was it might be it
for sure might be and here's the deal
you're bringing stuff from your past to
this relationship too
the difference is you've judged yours as
the right way and hurts us the wrong way
and what i would suggest you do is to
stop saying either or and you all
develop y'all's way
and some of that will be you sitting
down with her and creating an
environment where she doesn't feel like
you're gonna judge everything that comes
out of her mouth or beat her up with
your charts and your graphs because you
can have violence in a house two ways
you can have violence with facts and you
can have violence with silence too
and she haunts you by just walking away
and saying i need some time
it haunts you right
and you haunt her
by saying
well just quit eating that that's why
you're fat
and and i just made that up i don't
think you'd ever say that please tell me
you don't say that okay
i'm trying to be egregious here
but people say no i'm just telling the
truth man i'm just saying like you said
you solved that problem well dude
there's not the
yes you're factually correct and that
hurts people you know what i mean
and so your answers can be just as
painful for her as her silence is for
you and so instead of saying i have the
right way i was raised the right way and
i can see from the way your parents did
stuff
man you got it the wrong way and i don't
know if
man you can look at life like that i'm
tell you you're gonna be lonely
or you're gonna have all these answers
you have all these figured out you're
gonna spend a lot of time on the
internet
or
you can come down and say man in my
house we just did it like this tell me
about how you did it in your house
and
we get to create how we do it in our
house
which means i'm gonna have to learn
that when you come and say hey this
happened at work today you're not asking
for my opinion on what to do next
you're just inviting me into your life
and you're to have to learn that when
i'm frustrated i want to have a
conversation sooner rather than later
and you can't hide from me
does that make sense
yeah no totally
yeah and so i want you to approach this
with humility not with i've got this
figured out and she needs to know if
she's going to get on the jessie train
it's less about is she going to figure
out the right way that you do things or
are you all going to figure out the
right way that you all do things and the
way you all do things will change over
and over and over again throughout time
now hear me say does she need to take a
break yep does she need to circle back
and have conversations and face things
head-on with you i think that's healthy
and i think that's wise yes
i do
i don't think that's a stick to to beat
her up with though
i think she's gonna have to learn a new
way of doing things and i think you're
gonna have to learn the way of doing
things too would you agree with that or
tell me i'm crazy
no yeah no i i agree so will you stick
by her side while she learns a new way
to love somebody
absolutely
will you commit to her to learning a new
way to love somebody too
yes will you never ever ever as long as
you live bring up her periods again
as an excuse for why she did something
ever no i won't ever
i won't do that
ever and this is just a personal thing
it's probably because i have a daughter
dude
but
i don't know dude don't call the girls
chicks i don't maybe that's cool i don't
know i i i don't know
no i don't call it call will you do you
call her to me call her
my i don't know call whatever i don't
know i'm trying to think of things i
call my wife and
i don't know
treat her with the utmost deepest
respect
as though
she was created on earth just for you
and love her like that not like a puzzle
to fix or an engine to tune up
and then in a year if you find out man i
have cherished her
i have dug deep in jesse i've tried to
figure some stuff out i've tried to be a
little more quiet and a little more
honoring and a little more tell me how
that feels man
thank you for sharing that with me
yeah absolutely and try that and if
after a year just that's not a thing or
after two months six months like this is
too much work that's great that's why
you're dating you all aren't married
but my guess is you're gonna find a lot
about jesse
and you're gonna find a lot about her
and dude
can i ask can i ask you one more quick
question i know we got to wrap up
sure
are you scared of how much you love her
um no
no
no because sometimes i've seen guys in
your situation
come up with reasons to leave somebody
before
they get left
no i don't think i'm i'm on that boat
she's all in on jesse
i think so i know so awesome so try this
and then shoot me an email and tell me
that was the stupidest thing i've ever
done
i want you to call her today
and say listen i talked to uh you don't
tell you talk to me
or you can say hey i think that
for the last six seven months
i've acted like i'm right all the time
and that you've got all these problems
and i want you to know that i love you
and i'm gonna start doing a better job
of just listening to you
and i'm gonna do a better job of
hearing you out and honoring your space
and here's the magic words
i want us to go have breakfast somewhere
and talk about
ways we could communicate better with
one another
and just be quiet and see what she says
she'll probably faint and you'll have to
hang out for 15 or 20 minutes until she
comes back too
my hope is she'll say
man that's awesome let's go to breakfast
she may say you're an idiot and i want
my old bearded truck driver back that
may happen that's her prerogative too
but man
if you can practice
letting her teach you what safety feels
like for her
man she'll be willing to have those hard
conversations she'll be willing to lean
into some hard stuff and i'm not saying
it's soft i'm not saying be like no dude
i'm saying is y'all co-create what this
thing's gonna look like together
you're a good man jesse she's lucky to
have you
never talk about periods and chicks
again
all right good that's the last time i'll
say that